willkommen zu Bild live schönen guten
morgen an diesem Dienstag es wird mehr
mehr und immer noch mehr der
gaspreishammer alleine in diesem Jahr
müssen wir
26,6 Milliarden Euro mehr für Gas
bezahlen ja was für eine Summe das hat
das Vergleichsportal Verivox für Bild
ausgerechnet ja vergleichen wir mal mit
dem letzten Jahr der lag der
durchschnittliche Gaspreis je
Kilowattstunde bei 6,56 Cent dieses Jahr
sind es schon 15,52 Cent die Gaspreise
gehen immer mehr durch die Decke und das
ist noch nicht alles die Bundesbank
schlägt jetzt inflationsalarm die
Bundesbanker rechnen damit dass die
Inflation in den kommenden Monaten auf
über 10% steigen wird die Preise
schnellen also in die Höhe und wir
rutschen in eine Rezession schauen wir
auf das was die Bundesbank mitgeteilt
hat dort heißt es in dieser Mitteilung
die Inflationsrate die dürfte unter dem
Strich in den nächsten Monaten in den
zweistelligen Bereich vorrücken die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen des Krieges
werden immer mehr spürbar fassen wir
also noch mal zusammen
26,6 Milliarden Euro müssen Gaskunden in
diesem Jahr mehr bezahlen eine
unvorstellbare Summe und wir haben
einmal ausgerechnet was sie dafür alles
so bekommen würden für 26,6 Milliarden
bekommen sie
99.737 nagelneue Ferraris ja wirklich
der Wahnsinn oder sie könnten davon auch
einfach ein Familienhäuser bauen und
zwar
91.399 oder ein weiteres Beispiel vier
Mal die Beerdigung von Queen Elizabeth
bezahlen und das ist noch nicht alles
wenn Sie wollen ich befürchte das wollen
sie nicht aber sie könnten eine
viereinhalb mal den Berliner
pannenflughafen Brauen ja oder
vielleicht den unterirdischen
Stuttgarter Hauptbahnhof bekommen Sie
für 26,6 Milliarden Euro ganze 3 mal
also es ist eine riesige Summe wir
sprechen darüber mit unseren
bildpolitik-chef Jan Schäfer hier bei
uns im Studio schönen guten Morgen tja
Jan was für eine Summe was bedeutet das
für Geldbeutel von uns allen ja das
bedeutet für ganz ganz viele Menschen
eigentlich für alle die mit Gas heizen
oder die Gas irgendwie benutzen im
Alltag dass sie mehr für Gas ausgeben
müssen und weniger für andere Dinge zur
Verfügung haben und das was wir sehen
was die Bundesbank ja auch sagt diese
Inflationsrate von zehn Prozent und mehr
die wir möglicherweise in diesem Monat
im September schon erleben heißt nichts
anderes als dass wir 100 Euro vor einem
Jahr hatten und die nur noch 90 Euro
wert sind das heißt ein massiver
Kaufkraftverlust statt 100 Euro ist der
Gegenwert dann nur noch 90 Euro und das
bedeutet dass man irgendwo sparen muss
wenn man beim Gast nicht sparen kann
oder will dann bedeutet das
beispielsweise dass man in der Kneipe
ein oder zwei Bier weniger trinken muss
denn man kann ein Euro nur einmal
ausgeben und das Ende der
Preissteigerung ist noch lange nicht in
Sicht was muss jetzt passieren kann das
überhaupt noch gestoppt werden
kurzfristig kann das nicht gestoppt
werden und wir sehen einmal mehr das
Inflation das größte Gift für eine
Marktwirtschaft auch für ein Sozialstaat
ist denn Inflation macht Menschen
ärmer und das ist ganz entscheidend das
hören wir häufig in der Politik anders
da heißt es häufig Inflation ist
eigentlich ganz gut klar weil sie den
Start entschuldigt das heißt politiker
können mehr Schulden machen die am Ende
weniger wert sind aber für die ganz
normalen Bürger ist Inflation ein
wahnsinnig gefährliches Gift und
kurzfristig kann man da nichts machen
das ist jetzt einfach so die Inflation
die wir haben der ist in der
Vergangenheit vieles schief gelaufen
mittelfristig ganz klar muss die
Europäische Zentralbank gegensteuern sie
hat die Aufgabe Inflation einzudämmen
das heißt die EZB muss die Zinsen weiter
erhöhen aber auch der Start kann etwas
tun er kann beispielsweise darauf
verzichten dass die Teuerung zusätzlich
angeheizt wird beispielsweise durch
Preistreiberei bei Gebühren die erhoben
werden oder auch bei
Krankenkassenbeiträgen all das kommt ja
auf die Bundesbürger zu und da könnte
der Staat sagen nein das machen wir
nicht hier gibt es einen Moratorium um
die Preise nicht weiter anzuheizen deine
Einschätzung in was für einen Herbst
Winter gehen wir da rein
ja es ist wie so eine Nebelwand in die
man reingeht wir hören sehr sehr
beunruhigende Dinge aus vielen Branchen
Firmen die sich diese hohen Gaspreise
nicht mehr leisten können und damit
meine ich nicht nur
Bäckereien sondern da gibt es auch
wirklich Industriebetriebe die jetzt die
Produktion drosseln die zum Teil darüber
nachdenken auch Produktion ins Ausland
wo Energie deutlich günstiger immer noch
ist als in Deutschland zu verlagern auf
der anderen sitzplatzverluste dann für
uns die Bundesbank sagt beispielsweise
wir gehen jetzt in eine Rezession über
den Winter und es ist nicht ganz klar ob
wir da im Frühjahr auch dann oder im
Sommer schon wieder rauskommen gibt die
ersten
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute die für
das nächste Jahr insgesamt damit rechnen
dass die deutsche Wirtschaft schrumpft
das bedeutet immer das Lohnerhöhungen
lange nicht so hoch ausfallen können wie
in einer guten Konjunktur vielleicht
müssen Löhne auch können Löhne auch gar
nicht steigen möglicherweise gibt es
auch Entlassung ein einen Sonnenschein
oder einen einen vielleicht Stern am
Himmel den gibt es auch an diesem Morgen
es gibt viele viele Firmen die trotz
dieser
wirklich merkwürdigen Gemengelage
Stellen offen haben also Mitarbeiter
suchen das ist anders als in vergangenen
Krisen da war es ja oft so dass dann
viele viele tausende hunderttausende
Menschen entlassen wurden und ihren Job
verloren haben das könnte diesmal anders
sein denn der Bedarf an Mitarbeitern ist
trotzdem wirklich dramatischen Aussicht
sehr sehr hoch in vielen Branchen ein
kleiner Hoffnungsschimmer in der Krise
herzlichen Dank bildpolitikchef Jan
Schäfer
[Musik]